Dr. Peterson.
Thank you for coming.
We all,
uh,
appreciate it a lot.
Uh,
I wanted to get your opinion on censorship that we're seeing on the web.
it's accelerating.
You were a very notable example.
You were locked out of your Gmail and B and Trump account.
Pardon me?
Oh yeah.
Trump just got a deleted by an air in person,
you know,
now they're saying that perhaps this was just a contractor and you know,
maybe,
uh,
someone from Twitter who's gone in a very far left direction,
youtube has gone in a very far left erection.
Uh,
I'm just wondering,
I've started a,
an alternative to youtube called Pew Tube.
Uh,
what kind of,
um,
what,
what do you see for possible solutions and just your thoughts in general or is
it not?
Here's an
crazy thought,
but I'm going to tell it to you anyways.
Sorry.
I was just reading one of Ray Kurzweil's books,
I think it was called,
how to make a mind.
I really liked it actually.
It helped me understand how the brain compresses information because the world
is really complicated,
so you have to make a low resolution representation of it to live in it.
And he actually explained to me in a way that I hadn't really understood how the
brain might do that neurologically.
So that was cool.
But you know,
Kurt's while this guy who thinks that he's a smart guy,
a very smart guy and uh,
he's invented a fair bit of high end technical technological,
uh,
software and hardware and he's the guy that thinks that we're heading towards
the singularity.
And so the singularity is,
you know,
how processing speed doubles every 18 months and like hard disk capacity every
year and there's a bunch of doublings going on,
a huge number of them and they accelerate exponentially.
And so it's probably,
we're probably three years away,
maybe even less then from building a computer that has,
is the capacity to make as many calculations as reasonable estimates of the
calculating capacity of the human brain are,
are currently set up 18 months away,
two years away,
something like that.
And then we're 18 months away from having one that's twice that fast and then 18
months away from having one that's twice as fast as that.
So that's like say six years
and we've got something that's eight times as smart as a human being.
But there's a twist on that.
And this is Kurt swells twist,
which is as soon as you make a machine smart enough to make the next machine
that's smarter than it,
which is sort of what we're doing because computers are so fast that that will
scale up to near infinite computing computing power almost instantaneously.
Now you think?
No,
probably not.
And Allen,
Bob Gates partner has written critiques of Kurtzweil while and you know,
you might think if something's impossible then it won't even if you don't know
why.
And there's reasons to not think that that will happen.
But Kurzweil's traced back the doubling of computing power way before the
existence of the transistor and it's been ridiculously stable,
crazily stable.
So God only knows what we're coming up with here.
You know,
and you don't know what something of infinite computing power might be like.
Like you seriously don't know.
And there are serious people who are very,
very,
very worried about that.
They're very worried,
for example,
that companies like Facebook and Google will manage that first.
And you know,
those companies are already making censorship AI bots.
And that's what,
that's smart.
It's sort of like making really fast robots that can shoot people.
It's not that smart.
And we're doing that to very rapidly.
And you know,
I know some guys who work in advanced AI and you know how you look,
you watch the term terminator movies and you see the robots that miss when they
shoot at you.
Like they're not very bright because the bright ones not only shoot at where you
are,
but they estimate where you're going to be when you make your escape moves and
they shoot their simultaneously and their death rate is 100% and so there's no
war against the robots.
I mean,
when those things get going,
they're going to be so much faster than us that will look like we're moving
through molasses to them.
So
you know,
so maybe what we're deciding now with all of our individual decisions about
censorship and the way that we're going to construct the world and all that is
exactly what kind of super intelligence we're going to bring into being.
And I would suggest that we try to bring one in that's good and moral rather
than one that's evil and demonic,
right?
So what can we do about that?
There's only one answer to that.
As far as I know that that works is gay rock together.
You're going to be the person who's working in Ai,
right?
I know some of these people,
they better be good people because they're going to build whatever they're like
into their machines.
They better have their head screwed on straight cause they're going to get
amplified like math.
And I don't like what's happening with Google and Facebook and Youtube,
they're building censorship bots predicated on a certain kind of ideology and
the kind of ideology that we outlined today.
It's a very bad idea.
Hopefully good people will stop that.
So then that,
what that means is that your moral obligation is to be good.
And the way you do that is first by stopping being bad.
And everyone can do that a little bit.
So I hope that's what everyone does because the consequences of not doing it are
not going to be pleasant.
They never are.
Thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
this question is about your biblical lecture series.
Um,
I liked that one because it's about genesis,
which is usually ignored as being,
we're this post enlightenment society,
you don't need these ancient creation myths.
And also I thought revelations kind of gets the same treatment as being
dismissed because it's the crazy hallucinogenic trip.
That's why some isolated mad man in the middle of the Mediterranean.
So I was wondering if after you're done with genesis,
if you were thinking about doing revelations,
not without traversing the,
the geography in between.
Okay.
Yeah.
I want to walk through the whole thing if I can do that before I expire.
So,
I mean,
I've read it and thought about it and it's such a strange book,
a because it's really big among the evangelical Republican types and you'd think
really,
really that's the book that's,
but you're relying on,
have you read it?
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's a crazy hallucinogenic trip.
That's what revelation is now.
That's not to play it down because God only knows about crazy hallucinogenic
trips,
that's for sure.
I mean there's,
there's accruing evidence.
I would say that a tremendous amount of the religious orientation of human
beings,
you know,
that deep mythological,
symbolic orientation is in no small part a consequence of humanities
experimentation with psychedelics substances.
I think that's,
that the evidence for that I think has become virtually an overwhelming.
So
anyways,
I will get there.
Maybe,
probably not because at the rate I'm going through the first stories,
it'll take me forever to get there.
Right.
But that's okay.
So thank you.
Yeah.
Dr. Peterson.
Thank you.
First of all,
it's great pleasure being here.
It's awesome to see you live.
Um,
I basically got into your work's just earlier this year and I had an original
question,
but your talk today kind of made me decide to change my mind.
I was going to ask,
um,
do you feel as though would you agree with me and the sentiment that the left
has pushed so hard for total control of our society over the last however many
years?
It's almost to a point where saying 2013 was a different time.
Um,
would you say that because they pushed so hard,
they've created this backlash and the backlash created,
caused them to backlash back again.
So they doubled down with their ideology and then they get,
they lose another argument.
They lose another ideological war.
They knew lose another me more and they doubled down and they double down again
and again and they just can't seem to meme,
they can't seem to argue.
They can't seem,
they can't,
they don't want to have an intellectual discussion.
And as an interpretation of what you were saying,
there is no,
there doesn't seem to be any,
any,
any care of what's right with them.
They just want power.
They just want,
they just want to win.
Um,
do you,
would you agree with the sentiment that they're burning themselves out and
creating the mass red pilling of the,
uh,
conservative movement that we see going on?
Would you possibly think to maybe they've committed suicide and,
and talks like this,
people like yourself,
Ben Shapiro and others who talk to people like what the subjects that we do the
taboo of nowadays,
um,
possibly that this,
this is the answer to defeat the,
the leftist strangle angle hold
it's on.
Our society will untangle some of that.
Okay.
So first of all,
well first of all,
the first observation is a really interesting one because you know that things
can go out of hand very,
very rapidly.
Yeah.
And the reason they do that is because of positive feedback loops.
Now the thing that Kurzweil talks about is a positive feedback loop.
And intelligent machine makes another intelligent machine that makes another
intelligent machine.
And that's a positive feedback loop.
And that can spiral upwards out of control very rapidly.
And that's when polarization is,
it's like,
I tap you,
you tap me,
I slapped you,
you punch me.
Well up it goes.
Well.
I think that's partly why in the New Testament,
for example,
there's an injunction that says turn the other cheek,
resist not evil.
Why?
Because otherwise you get into a positive feedback loop and then you better look
the hell out and things can tilt very,
very rapidly.
I mean,
all you have to do,
look at what happened in World War one new unexpected that it was like one,
one relatively minor member,
I think of the aristocracy,
if I remember correctly,
was assassinated in one minor little country.
It's like bang,
everything fell apart.
And that's positive feedback loops,
right?
And so that's what we're in right now and we've got to be,
and that's a really chaotic time.
And so I would say maintain self control and don't aim to win.
Amen.
Peace.
Because winning,
that's,
that's not peace.
It's better to aim for peace.
You know,
I've got this talk coming up in November 11th I'm quite worried about it because
I know there's going to be protesters there and that they've been emboldened by
the fact that they shut the talk down before and I want to make a video.
I'll probably do it tomorrow,
telling everyone that comes to that meeting to like watch their bloody step and
stay out of the gutter because you just,
we're at,
we're at a point now where under the wrong circumstances,
if the wrong person does the wrong thing,
that the consequences will be very great.
Now we can't predict which action is going to precipitate that and or even if
that will happen,
but it's chaotic enough so that it could happen.
So you know,
so govern yourselves accordingly.
Now the problem is is that there are people who would be happy if there was
blood running in the street.
They're the same sort of people that shoot up high schools or kill innocent,
you know,
elementary school kids just to show what they're made of and what they believe.
And that's a big problem.
But for the rest of us,
like hopefully calmer heads can prevail.
And so it really is important not to win it.
It's like fighting with your wife.
You don't win.
You can't because you have to live with her because you can't win.
But maybe you can solve the problem and bring about peace.
And so you've got to practice doing that.
Practice restraint.
And remember too,
that these people that you're talking about who had radical leftists is most of
the time,
they're not like they're 95% like you.
And if you pull them out of the mob,
they're just like your,
your neighbor's 19 year old kid who's kind of clueless and rebellious,
right.
And who you might even like you put them in the mob.
It's a whole different thing.
And so you got to remember that too.
Oh,
this fear of social isolation,
kind of how they're acting,
how you say no,
it's just that they're possessed by these ideas,
but,
but only partially,
you know,
you hardly find it full blooded.
Absolutely committed radical leftist activist.
You know,
like there are some,
but not very many.
Most of it.
It's just fragmentary behavior.
And you have to remember that like when the students come out to protest me was
a case,
particularly at McMaster,
have to remember these kids,
they're not much different than my kids.
They are when they're in a stupid mob behind a hammer and sickle flag,
you know,
but,
but
you don't want to make a low resolution,
homogenous representation of them.
And so,
and so you,
that's why again,
I think instead of winning,
you turn to your own development.
You turn to your own development,
you do what you can to stop doing the things that you're doing that aren't good
because you're not going to hurt anybody.
If you do that,
all you're going to do is help.
And otherwise you'll participate in this polarization.
And that's unless you want that.
And you know,
there's a dark part of people that it's part of the part that voted for Trump
would like to burn things to the ground.
It's like to hell.
I know how people felt when they went into the voting booth.
It was like Hillary,
Hillary dealt with it.
Trump,
you know,
and that's,
that's a hell of a thing to say to hell with it.
You know,
although I could,
I could certainly understand that sentiment.
So we have to be careful and all of you people who are here,
who are advocates of free speech and who are theoretically happy to come hear me
speak.
It's like,
I really do believe in,
I truly believe this and this is something I learned in part from social knits
and apart from y'all I that the way that you set the world straight is by
constraining the malevolence in your own heart.
And that's no joke,
man.
That's no easy thing and that's a good voyage,
people to go on if they want something difficult and worthwhile to do.
So thank you very much.
Okay,
just a quick thing.
Uh,
we're not going to have time for pictures so you're,
unless you're,
yours is the last question.
Okay.
So sorry to everybody else,
but you're the last one.
Okay.
Hi,
doctor said,
thanks for coming.
Uh,
my question is a little bit off topic from everything else tonight,
but I really wanted to hear what you had to say about it.
Um.